hello everybody
welcome to cs224n
lecture 10. this is going to be
primarily on pre-training but we will
also discuss
sub word models a little bit and review
transformers
okay so we have a lot of exciting things
uh to
get into today but some reminders about
the class assignment five uh is being
released today
assignment 4 was due a minute ago so uh
if you're done with that congratulations
if not i hope that
the late days go well
assignment 5 is
on pre-training and transformers so
these lectures are going to be very
useful to you for that and it doesn't
cover anything after these lectures
um
all right so uh today let's kind of take
a little peek through what the outline
will be um we haven't talked about sub
word modeling yet and and sort of we
should have um and so we're going to
talk a little bit about sub words you
saw these in assignment for uh all just
you know as the data that we provided to
you with your machine translation system
but uh we're gonna talk a little bit
about why they're so ubiquitous in nlp
uh because they are used in pre-trained
models um i mean they're used in a
number of different models but but uh
when we discuss pre-training it's
important to know that sub words are a
part of it um then we'll sort of
motivate we'll go on another journey of
motivation of uh motivating model
pre-training from word embedding so
we've already seen pre-training in some
sense in the very first lecture of this
course
because we pre-trained individual word
embeddings that don't take into account
their contexts on very large text
corpora and saw that they were able to
encode a lot of useful things about
language
so after we do the motivation
uh we'll go through model pre-training
three ways and we're going to you know
reference actually the lecture on
tuesday so this is why we're gonna
review a little bit of the transformers
stuff we'll talk about model
pre-training and decoders like a
transformer decoder that we saw last
week in encoders and then encoder
decoders in each of these three cases
we're going to talk a little bit about
sort of what things you could be doing
and then popular models that are in use
across research and an industry
then we're going to talk a little bit
about you know what do we think
pre-training is teaching um this is
going to be very brief uh actually a lot
of the interpretability and analysis
lecture in two weeks is going to talk
more about sort of the the mystery and
the scientific problem of figuring out
what these models are learning about
language
through pre-training objectives but
we'll sort of get a peek and then we'll
talk about very large models and
in-context learning so if you've heard
of
gpt-3 for example we're going to just
briefly touch on that here and i think
we'll discuss more about it in the
course later on as well
okay so we got a lot to do let's jump
right in
so word structure and subwood models um
let's think about sort of the
assumptions we've been making in this
course so far when we give you an
assignment when we talk about uh
training word to vec for example uh we
made this assumption about a language's
vocabulary in particular we've made an
assumption that has a fixed vocabulary
of something like tens of thousands
maybe a hundred thousand i don't know a
number of yeah
some some relatively large it seems
number of words and that seems sort of
like pretty good um so far at least in
what we've done and we build this
vocabulary from the set that we train
say word to vet on
and then here's a crucial thing any
novel word any word that you did not see
at training time
is sort of mapped to a single
unk token there are other ways to handle
this but you sort of have to do
something and a frequent method is to
you know map them all to unk so so let's
walk through what this sort of sort of
means in english
you learn embeddings you map them it all
works then you have a variation on a
word like tasty with a bunch of a's
right and your model isn't smart enough
to know that that sort of means like
very tasty maybe uh and so it maps it to
unk because it's just a dictionary look
up miss
and then you have a typo like learn
and that maps to unk as well uh
potentially if it wasn't in your
training set you know some people make
uh typos but not all of them will be
seen at training time and then you'll
have novel items right so this could be
the first time that you've ever seen you
as the student in 2224n have seen the
word transformerify
um but i get
the feeling you sort of have a notion of
what it's supposed to mean right like
maybe add transformers to or turn into
using transformers or turn into a
transformer or something like that and
this is also going to be mapped to unk
even though you've seen transformer and
if i
okay and so somehow the conclusion we
have to come to is that looking at words
as just like the individual sequences of
characters you know uniquely identifies
that word and that's sort of how we
should parameterize things it's just
wrong
um and so uh
not only is this true in english but in
many languages this finite vocabulary
assumption makes even less sense so
already it doesn't make sense in english
but english is uh it's not the worst for
english so so
morphology is um
the study of the structure of words and
english is known to have pretty simple
morphology in uh in
kind of uh specific ways and when
languages have complex morphology it
means you have
longer words more complex words that get
modified more and each one of them
occurs less frequently and that should
sound like a problem right if a word
occurs less frequently you'll be less
likely to show up in your training set
and you know maybe it'll show up in your
test set never in your training set now
it's mapped to unk and you don't know
what to do
so an example you know swahili verbs can
have hundreds of conjugations so
each conjugation encodes important
information about the sentence that in
english might be represented through say
more words but in swahili it's mapped uh
onto the verb as you know prefixes and
suffixes and the like this is called
inflectional morphology and so you can
have hundreds of conjugations i've just
sort of pasted this this wiktionary
block uh just to give you a small sample
of just the huge number of conjugations
there are and so trying to memorize
independently a meaning of each one of
these words is just just not the right
answer
so
this is going to be a very brief
overview and so what we're going to do
is take one
let's say class of
algorithms for subword modeling
that have been kind of
developed to try to take a middle ground
between two options one option is saying
everything is just like individual words
either i know the word and i saw it at
training time or i don't know the word
and it's like unk and then sort of
another extreme option is to say it's
just characters
right so like i get a sequence of
characters and then my neural network on
top of my sequence of characters has to
learn
everything has to learn how to combine
words and stuff so subword models in
general just means looking at the sort
of internal structure of words somehow
looking below the word level but this
group of
of models is going to try to meet a
middle ground so byte pair encoding
what we're going to do is we're going to
learn a vocabulary from a training data
set again so now we have a training data
set instead of just saying oh everything
that was split by my heuristic word
splitter like
spaces in english for example is going
to be a word in my vocabulary um we're
going to
learn the vocabulary using a greedy
algorithm in this case so here's what
we're going to do um we start with a
vocabulary containing only characters so
that's our extreme right that's our
at the very least if you've seen all the
characters
then you know that you can you'll never
have an unk right because you see a word
you've never seen it before you just
split it into its characters and then
you try to see you know deal with it
that way
and then also an end of word symbol
and then we'll iterate over this
algorithm we'll say use the corpus of
text find common adjacent letters so
maybe a and b are very frequently
adjacent
add
the pair of them together
as a single sub word into your
vocabulary
now replace instances of that character
pair with the new sub word repeat until
your desired vocabulary size so maybe
you start with a small character
vocabulary and then you end up with that
same small character vocabulary plus a
bunch of sort of entire words or parts
of words so notice how apple an entire
word looks like apple but then app maybe
this is sort of the first part
the first subword of application or up
yeah
and then lee uh
i guess i should have not put the
hash there
but you know maybe you learned lee as
like the end of a word for example
and so what you end up with is uh you
know a vocabulary where common things
you get to map to themselves and then
rare sequences of characters you kind of
split as little as possible
and it doesn't always end up so nicely
that you learn like morphologically
relevant suffixes like lee
but you can you know try to split things
somewhat reasonably and and if you have
enough data the sub vocabulary you learn
tends to be okay so this was originally
used in machine translation um and now a
similar method word piece uh which we
won't go over in this lecture is used in
pre-trained models but you know the idea
is effectively the same and you end up
with vocabularies that look a lot like
this so if we go back to our um
[Music]
if we go back to our examples of where
you know word level nlp was failing us
then um
then you have hat mapping to hat okay
that's good you have hat mapping to hat
because that was a common enough
sequence of characters that it was
actually incorporated into our sub-word
vocabulary
right and then you have learn mapping to
learn so common words good
and that means that the model the neural
network that you're going to process
this text with does not need to say
combine the letters of learn and hat in
order in order to try to like derive the
meaning of these words uh from the
letters because you can imagine that
might be difficult but then when you get
a word that you have not seen before
you are able to decompose it
and so if you've seen tasty with varying
numbers of a's at trading time
you know maybe you actually get some of
the same sub words or similar sub words
that you're splitting it into at
evaluation time so we never thought
tasty enough to like with you know
however many a's in order to add it into
our sub word vocabulary um but we're
still able to split it into things and
then the neural network that runs on top
of these uh sub embeddings could be able
to sort of induce that oh yeah this is
one of those things where people like
you know
chain letters together chain uh vowels
together in english for emphasis
so misspellings still pretty much mess
you up so now learn
with this misspelling might be mapped to
two sub words but if you saw
misspellings like this frequently enough
maybe you could learn sort of to handle
it it still messes up the model though
and uh um
but at the very least it's not just an
unk right it seems clearly better than
that and then transformerify maybe in
the best this is sort of optimistic but
maybe in the best case right you were
able to say ah yes this is transformer
and if i
um again the sub words that you learn
don't actually tend to be this well
morphologically motivated i think so if
i is like a clear like
suffix in english that has a very common
and replicable meaning when you apply it
to nouns um that's derivational
morphology um but you know you're able
to sort of comb compose the word of tr
the meaning of transformerify possibly
from its two sub-word constituents
and so when we talk about words being
input to transformer models pre-trained
transformer models throughout the
entirety of this lecture we will be
talking about sub words so i might say
word uh and what i mean is you know
possibly a full word also possibly a sub
word okay so when we say a sequence of
words the transformer the pre-trained
transformer has no idea sort of whether
it's dealing with words or sub-words um
uh when it's doing itself attention
operations
and so this can be a problem you can
imagine if you have really weird
sequences of characters you can actually
have an individual single word mapped to
as many sub words as it has characters
that can be a problem because suddenly
you know you have a 10 word sentence but
one of the words is mapped to you know
20 sub words now you have a 30 word
sentence where 20 of the 30 words are
just one uh real word um so keep this in
mind but
you know i think it's important for sort
of this open vocabulary assumption it's
important in english and it's even more
important in many other languages
and the actual algorithm i mean you can
go into the actual algorithms they've
done for this
bite pair encoding is sort of my
favorite for going over briefly a word
piece you can also take a look at
okay
any questions on subwords
i guess john um
oh great great point so this means that
you should be combining this sub so this
sub word is not the end of a word
taa
is sort of telling the model so if i had
taa with no hashes
that's a separate subword that means
there's an entire word that is
ta or at the very least it's not the end
of the word see how here i don't have
the hashes at the end it's because this
is indicating that this is at the end of
the word different word schemes uh
differ on whether you should put
something at the beginning of the word
if it does like begin a word or if you
should put something at the end of the
word if it doesn't end the word right so
when the tokenizer is running over your
data so you've got something that's
tokenizing you know this sentence in the
worst case
um oh yeah in the worst case
it says like n that's a whole word give
it just the word in no hashes that's a
whole word give it just the word the no
hashes and then
maybe
over here at sub words right we've got
this weird word sub words and it splits
it into sub and words and so sub
it's going to give it the sub word with
s u b hash
to indicate that it's part of this
larger word
sub-words as opposed to the word
sub like submarine which would be
different
yep that's a great question
okay
great um so that was our note on sub
word modeling and uh you can you know
sub words are important for example um
in
in you know a lot of translation
applications it's why we gave you sub
words on the machine translation
assignment um now let's talk about model
pre-training and word embeddings so i i
love i love being able to go to this
slide so so we saw this quote at the
beginning of the class you shall know a
word by the company it keeps and this
was sort of one of the things that we
used to summarize distributional
semantics this idea that word to vect
was sort of well motivated in some way
because the meaning of a word can be
thought of as being derived from the
kind of co-occurrence statistics of
words that co-occur around it and um
that was just fascinatingly effective i
think
but there's this other quote actually
from the same person so we have j.r
firth um 1935 compared to our quote
before from 1957 and the second quote
says the complete meaning of a word is
always contextual
and no study of meaning apart from a
complete context can be taken seriously
now again these are just things that we
can sort of think about and chew on
but it comes to mind right when you
when you embed words with word to vec
one of the issues is that you don't
actually look at its neighbors as you're
giving it and embedding
so if i have the sentence i record the
record um you know the two instances of
r-e-c-o-r-d
mean different things but they're given
the same word to back embedding
right because in word to vect you take
the string you map it to oh i've seen
the word record before you get that sort
of uh vector from your learned matrix
and you give it the same thing in both
cases
and so what we're going to be doing
today is actually not conceptually all
that different from training word to vec
word training you can think of as
pre-training just a very simple model
that only assigns an individual vector
to each unique word type each unique
element in your vocabulary today we'll
be going a lot farther than that but the
idea is very similar
so back in you know 2017 we would start
with pre-trained word embeddings
uh and again remember no context there
so so you give a word and embedding
independent of the context that it shows
up in and then you learn how to
incorporate the context it's not like
our nlp models never used context right
instead you would learn to incorporate
the context using you know your lstm or
if it's later in 2017 you know your
transformer
and and you would learn to incorporate
context um while training on the tasks
so you have some supervision maybe it's
machine translation supervision maybe
sentiment maybe question answering and
you would learn how to incorporate
context in your in your lstm or
otherwise
um through the signal of the training
instead of say through the word to x
signal and so you know sort of
pictographically you have these word
embeddings here so the the red are sort
of your word to vector bettings and
those are pre-trained
that and those take up some of the
parameters of your network and then
you've got your contextualization now
this looks like an lstm but it could be
whatever so this this may be
bi-directional you know encoder thing
here is not pre-trained and now that's
that's a lot of parameters that are not
pre-trained and then maybe you have some
sort of readout function at the end
right to predict whatever thing you're
trying to predict again maybe it's
sentiment maybe you're doing i don't
know topic labeling whatever you want to
do this is sort of the paradigm like you
set some sort of architecture and you
only pre-train the word embeddings
and so this isn't actually the
conceptually necessarily the biggest
problem um
because you know
we like to think in in deep learning
stuff that we have a lot of training
data for our for our objectives i mean
one of the things that we that we
motivated uh you know big deep neural
networks for is that they can take a lot
of data and they can learn patterns from
it but it does put the onus on our
downstream data to be sort of sufficient
to teach the contextual aspects of
language so you can imagine if you only
have a little bit of you know labeled
data for fine-tuning you're putting a
pretty big role on that data to say hey
maybe here's some pre-trained embeddings
but like how you handle like sentences
and how they compose and all that stuff
that's up to you
so if you don't have a lot of labeled
data for your downstream task you're
asking it to do a lot with uh you know a
large number of parameters that have
been initialized randomly
okay so like a small portion of the
parameters have been pre-trained
okay
so where we're going is pre-training
whole models i mean conceptually you
know we're we're pretty close to there
so
nowadays almost all
parameters in your neural network and
let's say a lot of research settings and
increasingly in industry are initialized
via pre-training
just like word-to-back parameters were
initialized and pre-training methods uh
in general
hide parts of the input
from the model itself
and then train the model to reconstruct
those parts
how does this connect to word to vec in
word to vect you know people don't
usually make this connection but it's
the following you have an individual
word
uh and it knows itself right because you
have the embedding for the center word
right from assignment two you have the
embedding for the center where it knows
itself
and you've masked out all of its
neighbors
you've hidden all of its neighbors from
it right every all of its window
neighbors you've hidden from it you ask
the center word to predict its neighbors
right
and so this is
this falls under the category of of
pre-training
all of these methods look similar you
hide parts of the input from the model
and train the model to reconstruct those
parts
the differences with full model
pre-training is that you don't give the
model just the individual word and have
it learn in a wedding of that word you
give it much more of the sequence and
have it predict uh you know held out
parts of the of the sequence we'll get
into the details there but but you know
the takeaway is that everything here is
pre-trained jointly
possibly with the exception of the very
last layer that predicts the label
okay and this has just been
exceptionally effective at building
representations of language
that just map similar things in language
to similar representations in these
encoders just like how word to vect map
similar words to similar vectors
it's been exceptionally effective at
making parameter initializations where
you start with these parameters that
have been pre-pre-trained and then you
fine-tune them on your labeled data
and then third they've been
exceptionally effective at defining
probability distributions over language
like in language modeling that are
actually
really useful to sample from in certain
cases
so these are three ways in which we
interact with pre-trained models we use
the representations just to compute
similarities we use them for parameter
initializations and we actually just use
them as as probability distributions
sort of how we trained them
okay
so let's uh we're going to get into some
technical parts here but i sort of want
to
think broad thoughts about about what
what we could do with pre-training and
what kind of things we could expect to
potentially learn
from this general method of hide part of
the input and then see other parts of
the input and then try to predict the
parts that you hid
okay so um
stanford university is located in blank
california
if we gave a model everything that was
not blanked out here and asked to
predict the middle
right the loss function would uh you
know train the model to predict palo
alto here i expect
okay so this is an instance of something
that you could imagine being a
pre-training objective you take in a
sentence you remove part of it and you
say recreate the part that i removed and
in this case if i just gave a bunch of
examples that looked like this it might
learn
you know sort of trivia thing here
okay here's another one i put blank fork
down on the table this one is under
specified uh right so this could be the
fork my fork
his fork her fork if you know
some
spark yeah a fork so this is you know
specifying the kinds of syntactic uh
categories of things that can sort of
appear in this context um so this is
another thing that you might be able to
learn from such an objective
here
so you have the woman walked across the
street checking for traffic over blank
shoulder
one of the things that could go over
here is her that's a co-reference
statement
so you could learn sort of connections
between entities in uh in a text where
one word woman can also co-refer to the
same entity in the world as this word uh
this pronoun her
here you could think about you know i
went to the ocean to see the fish
turtles seals and blank now here i don't
think there's a single correct answer as
to what we could see going into that
blank
but a model could learn a distribution
of the kinds of things that people might
be talking about when they one go to the
ocean and two are excited to see marine
life uh right so this is sort of a
semantic category a lexical semantic
category of things um that might sort of
be in the same set of interest as fish
turtles and seals in the context of i
went to the ocean
okay
so and you know i don't know i expect
that there would be examples of this in
a large corpus of text maybe maybe a
book
okay here's here's another example uh
overall the value i got
from the two hours watching it was the
sum total of the popcorn and the drink
the movie was blank
right and this is when i would sort of
like look out into the audience and say
was the movie bad or good but the movie
was bad uh
is my prediction here right and so this
is teaching you something about
sentiment about how people express
sentiment in language and so this is
even
looks like a task itself like do
sentiment analysis is sort of what you
need to do in order to figure out
whether the movie was bad or good or
maybe
maybe the word is neither bad or good
the movie was over or something like
that but like if you had to if you had
to choose between is bad or good more
likely right you sort of have to figure
out the sentiment of the text
uh
now that's really fascinating
okay
here's another one um ira went into the
kitchen to make some tea
standing next to iro zuko pondered his
destiny
zuko left the blank
okay so so this is a little easy because
we really only
show one place i guess we have another
now in destiny um but but this is sort
of talking reasoning about spatial
location and the movement of sort of
agents in in an imagined world we could
imagine text that has lines like this
person went into the place and was next
to so and so who left and did that and
didn't and so you have these like
relationships uh so here zuko left the
kitchen is the most likely thing that i
think would go here and it sort of
indicates that in order for a model to
learn to perform this
fill in the missing part task
it might need to
in general
figure out sort of where
things are and whether
statements mean or imply that locality
so standing next to
ira went into the kitchen now ira's in
the kitchen
and then standing next to iro means zuko
is now in the kitchen right and then you
know
zuko now leaves where well he was in the
kitchen before so this is sort of a very
basic sense of reasoning
now
this one uh here's a sentence i was
thinking about the sequence that goes 1
1 2 3 5 8 13 21 uh blank right so um
i don't know i can imagine people
writing stuff so this is the fibonacci
sequence and sort of you know you sum
these two to get the next one some of
these two to the next one some of these
two right and so you know you have this
running sum it's a famous sequence it
shows up in a lot of text on the
internet
you know and in general you have to
learn the algorithm
or just the formula i guess that that
defines the fibonacci sequence in order
to keep going
do models learn this in practice
wait and find out but but you would have
to learn it in order to get you know the
sequence to keep going and going and
going
okay so we're going to get into
uh specific pre-trained models specific
methods of pre-training now
so i'm going to go over a brief
review of transformer encoders decoders
and encoder decoders
because we're going to get into the sort
of technical bits now so before i do
that i'm going to pause
are there any questions
uh yeah there's an interesting question
asked about um
getting our model on
our input training data in advance
and maybe you can also answer this
question
nowadays
um sorry the first part of that question
was it are we over fitting our models to
what
when they're doing yeah training
got it yeah um
so that's a good point so we're using
very large models
and we might imagine that there's a risk
of overfitting
and in practice yeah it's actually
one of the more crucial things to do to
make pre-training work
so it turns out that you need to have a
lot a lot a lot of data like a lot of
data
and in fact we'll show results later on
where people
built a pre-trained model pre-trained it
on a lot of data and then like six
months later someone else came along was
like hey if you pre-trained it on 10
months later and changed almost nothing
else it would have gone even better now
was it overfitting i mean
uh you can sort of like
hold out some text during pre-training
right and sort of evaluate the
perplexity right the language modeling
performance on that held out text and it
tends to be the case that actually these
models are under-fitting right that we
need even larger and larger models to
express the complex interactions that
allow us to fit these data sets better
and so we'll talk about that when we
talk about bert
and one of the really interesting
results is that burt is under fit not
over fit but in principle yes it's a
problem to this potentially a problem to
overfit but we end up having a ton of
text in english at least although not in
every language and so um
yeah it's important to scale them but
currently our models don't seem over fit
to the pre-training text
okay any other questions
all right
so we saw this figure before right here
we saw this figure of a transformer
encoder decoder from this paper
attention is all you need um and uh
so we have a couple of things we're not
going to go over the form of attention
again today because we have a lot to go
over but i'm happy to chat about it more
on ed um
but so so in our encoder we have some
input sequence remember there's a
sequence of sub words now
each sub word gets a word embedding
and each index in the in the transformer
gets a position embedding
now remember that we have a finite
length that our uh sequence can possibly
be like 512
tokens that's that was that capital t
from last lecture so you have some
finite length so you have one embedding
of a position for every
index for all 512 indices
and then
you have all your word embeddings and
then the transformer encoder right was
this combination of
sort of sub modules that we walked
through line by line uh on tuesday right
multi-headed attention was sort of the
core building block um
and then we had residual and layer norm
right to help with passing gradients and
to help make training go better and
faster we had that feed forward layer
to
uh yeah process sort of the result of
the multi-headed attention another
residual and layer norm and then pass to
an identical transformer encoder block
here and these would be stacked i will
see a number of different configurations
here but i think you know six 12
of these sort of stacked together
okay
so that's a transformer encoder and
we're actually going to see whole models
today that are just transformer encoders
okay so we when we talked about machine
translation when we talked about the
transformer itself transformer encoder
decoder we talked about this whole thing
but you could actually just have this
left column you could actually just have
this right column as well
um although the right column changes a
little bit if you just have it so
remember the right column we had this
masked multi-head self-attention
right so where you can't look at the
future
um and someone asked actually about how
we decode from transformers given that
you have this sort of big chunking
operation it's a great question i won't
be able to get into it in detail today
but you have to run it once during the
decoding process for every time that you
decode to sort of predict the next word
uh i'll write out something on ed for
this so um
so in the mass multi-head self-attention
you're not allowed to look at the future
so that you sort of have this
well-defined objective of trying to do
language modeling um then we have
residual and layer norm the multi-head
cross attention remember it goes back to
the last layer of the transformer
encoder or the last transformer encoder
block
and then more residual layer norm
another feed forward layer
or as drill and there norm now if we
don't have an encoder here
right then we get rid of the uh cross
attention and residual and layer norm
here right so if we didn't have this
stack of encoders the decoders get
simpler because you don't have to attend
to them
but then again you also have these word
embeddings at the bottom and position
representations for the output sequence
okay so that's been review um let's talk
about pre-training through language
modeling so we've actually talked maybe
a little bit about this before and we've
seen language modeling in the context of
maybe just wanting to do it a priori so
language models were useful for example
in automatic speech recognition systems
they were useful in statistical machine
translation systems so
let's recall the language modeling task
you can say it's defined as modeling the
probability of a word at a given index t
of any word any given index given all
the words before it
and this probability distribution
is this is a distribution of words given
their past contexts
um
and so this is just saying for any you
know for any prefix here
iro goes to make
i want a probability of whatever the
next word should be so the observed next
word is tasty but you know
maybe there's is goes to make tea goes
to make hot water etc you can have a
distribution over what the next word
should be in this decoder and remember
that because of the masked
self-attention make can look back to the
word to or goes or iro but it can't look
forward to tasty
so there's a lot of data for this right
you just have text
and like voila you have language
modeling data it's free well it's once
you have the text it's freely you know
available you don't need to label it
and in english you have a lot of it
right this is not true of every language
by any means but in english you have a
lot of uh of pre-training data
and so
the you know the simple thing about sort
of pre-training is
well what we're going to do is we're
going to train a neural network to do
language modeling on a large amount of
text and we'll just save you know the
network the parameters of our trained
network to disk
so uh conceptually it's not actually
different from the things that we've
done before it's just sort of the intent
right we're training these parameters to
start using them for something else
later down the line but the language
modeling itself doesn't change
the decoder here doesn't change right
it's a transformer in pre-trained models
in in a modern because this is a sort of
a a newly popular concept
although you know back in 2015 was sort
of when this uh i think was first you
know effectively tried out and got some
interesting uh results
um but you know this could be anything
here
today it's mostly going to be
transformers and the models that we
actually observe
okay
so once you have your pre-trained
network what's the sort of default thing
you do to take to use it right and if
you take anything away from
this lecture in terms of just like
engineering practices that will be
broadly useful to you as you go off and
build things and study things maybe you
know uh as a machine learning engineer
or a computational social scientist or
et cetera um you know what people tend
to do is you pre-train your network on
just a lot of data lots of text learn
very general things and then
you adapt the network to whatever you
wanted to do so we had a bunch of
pre-training data and then maybe this is
a movie review that we're taking as
input here and we just apply
uh apply the
decoder that we sort of pre-trained
right start the parameters there
and then fine-tune it on whatever we
were sort of uh
wanting to do maybe this is a sentiment
analysis task so we run the whole uh
sequence through the decoder right get a
hidden state at the end at the very last
thing and then we predict you know maybe
plus or minus sentiment
and this is sort of adapting the
pre-trained network to the tasks this
pre-trained fine-tune paradigm is wildly
successful and you should really try it
uh whenever you're doing any nlp tasks
nowadays effectively
because this tends to be what what some
variant of this tends to be what works
best
okay so we've got a technical note now
um
so
if you don't like to think about
optimization or gradient descent um you
know maybe take a pass on this slide but
i encourage you to just think think for
a second about like why should this help
you know uh
training neural nets we we're we're
using gradient descent to try to find
some global minimum right of this
optimizat of this of this loss function
and
um you know we're sort of doing this in
two steps and the first step is you know
we have we get some parameters theta hat
by approximating
min over our uh sorry theta is the
parameters of the neural network so all
of the kqv
vectors in our transformer write the
word embeddings the position embeddings
it's just all
the parameters of our neural network um
and so we're doing min over all the
parameters of our theta we're trying to
approximate min over the parameters of
our neural network of our pre-training
loss which here was language modeling
of our of our parameters and uh
that let's just we just get this sort of
estimate of some parameters theta hat
and then we fine tune by approximating
um this min over theta of uh the
fine-tune loss maybe that's sentiment
right starting at theta hat so we
initialize our gradient descent at theta
hat and then we just sort of like let it
do what it wants
and it's just like
it's it's it just works um and in part
it has to be because you know
something about where we start is so
important not just in terms of sort of
gradient flow although that is a big
part of it but also it seems like you
know stochastic gradient descent sticks
relatively close
to
that pre-training initialization during
fine-tuning this is something that we
seem to observe in practice
right that that
somehow the locality of stochastic
gradient descent finding local minima
that are close to this theta hat that
was good for such a general problem of
language modeling
um it seems like yeah the local minima
of the fine-tuning loss because we don't
find or yeah the local minimum of the
fine-tuning loss tend to generalize well
when they're near to this theta hat that
we pre-trained and this is sort of a
mystery that we're still trying to
figure out more about
um and then also yeah maybe the
gradients right the gradients of the
fine-tuning loss near theta propagate
nicely so our network training goes
really well as well
okay so this is something to chew on um
but uh in practice it works i think it's
just still fascinating that it works
okay so um
we've talked about mainly the
transformer encoder decoder
and um
in fact right i said that we could have
just sort of the left-hand side encoders
uh in our to be pre-trained or just
decoders to be pre-trained or encoder
decoders and there are actually really
popular sort of famous models in each of
these three categories the kinds of
pre-training you can do
and the kinds of
applications or or uses of those
pre-trained models that are most natural
actually depend strongly on whether you
choose to pre-train an encoder a decoder
or an encoder decoder
and so i think it's useful as we go
through some of these popular
sort of model names that you need to
know and what they sort of what their
innovations were to actually split it up
into these categories
so we've already so here's the thing uh
we're going to go through these three
and they all have sort of benefits and
and in some sense drawbacks uh so the
decoders right
the the
really what we're talking about here
mainly is language models and we've seen
this so far we've talked about uh
pre-trained decoders and these are nice
to generate from
right so you can just sample from your
pre-trained language model and get
things that look like the text that you
were pre-training on
um but you know one problem is that you
can't condition on future words right so
we mentioned
in our modeling with lstms that just
like instead if you could when you can
do it
we said that having a bi-directional
lstm was actually just way more useful
than having a one-directional stm well
it's sort of true for transformers as
well so
if you can see how the arrows are
pointing here uh the arrows are pointing
up into the you know to the right so
this word is sort of looking back at its
past history
but but you know this word uh can't see
you can't contextualize with the future
whereas in the encoder block here in
blue just below it you sort of have all
pairs of interactions and so you know
when you're building representations it
can actually be super useful to know
what the future words are so so that's
what encoders get you right you get
bi-directional context
so you can condition on the future maybe
that helps you build up better
representations of language but
the question that we'll actually go
through here is well how do you
pre-train them
you can't pre-trade them as language
models because you have access to the
future so if you try to do that the loss
will just immediately be zero because
you can just see what the future is
that's not useful um and then and then
we'll talk about pre-trained encoder
decoders
which like
maybe the best of both worlds um but
also maybe unclear what's the best way
to pre-train them
they definitely have uh benefits uh for
both so
let's get into uh sort of some general
top
like a more yeah let's get into the
decoders first we'll go through all
three
okay so
um
when we're pre-training a language model
right we're we're creating it on this
objective we're trying to make it
approximate this probability of a word
given all of its previous words
um
what we end up doing and i showed this
sort of pictographically let's add some
math right we get a hidden state
uh h1 to ht for each of the words in the
input w1 to wt now remember words again
mean sub words here
okay and then um when we're fine-tuning
this right we can take the
representation this should be h t a h t
plus b
and then the picture here is right
here's h t it's the very last encoder
state
um and now this has sort of the rep it's
seen all of its history
right and so um
you can apply a linear layer here maybe
multiplying it by some parameters a and
b that were not pre-trained
and then you're predicting sentiment
maybe you know plus or minus sentiment
uh perhaps and so um you know look at
the red and the gray so most of the
parameters in my neural network have now
been pre-trained the very last layer
that's learning the sentiment uh
say decision
uh is it has not been pre-trained so
those have been randomly initialized and
when you when you take the loss of the
sentiment loss right you train not just
the linear layer here but you actually
back propagate the gradients all the way
through the entire pre-trained network
and fine-tune all of those parameters
right so it's not like you're just
training this at fine tuning time this
linear layer you're training the whole
network as a function of this
fine-tuning loss
and you know maybe it's bad that like
the linear layer wasn't pre-trained
in the grand scheme of things it's not
that many parameters
also
um so this is useful this is just one
way to interact with pre-trained models
right and so
what i want you to take away from this
is that there was a contract that we had
with the original model right the
contract was that it was defining
probability distributions
but when we're fine-tuning when we're
interacting with the pre-trained model
what we also have are just like the
trained weights and the network
architecture we don't need to use it as
a language model we don't need to use it
as a probability distribution when we're
actually fine-tuning it we're really
just using it for its initialization of
its parameters and saying oh this is
just
a transformer decoder that was
pre-trained by
and it happens to be really great in
that it when you find tuna on some on
some sentiment data it does a really
good job
okay but there's a second way to
interact with with decoder with
pre-trained decoders which is in some
sense even more natural it actually is
closer to the contract that we started
with so we don't have to just ignore the
fact that it was a probability
distribution entirely we can make use of
it while still fine-tuning it so here's
what we're going to do
so we can use them as a generator at
fine-tuning time by generator i mean
it's going to you know define this
distribution of words given their
contexts
and then we'll actually just fine tune
that probability distribution
so in a task like di like some kind of
turn based dialogue we might encode the
dialogue history as your past context
right so you know you have a dialogue
history of of some
things that people are saying back and
forth to each other you encode it as
words and you try to predict the next
words in the dialogue
right and maybe your pre-training
objective you looked at very general
purpose text from i don't know wikipedia
or books or something and you're
fine-tuning it as a language model but
you're fine-tuning it as a language
model
on this sort of domain-specific
distribution of text like dialogue or
maybe summarization where you paste in
the whole document and then say
a specific word and then the summary and
say predict predict the summary and so
what this looks like is again a fine
tuning time here
you have your h1 to ht is equal to the
decoder of the words and then your you
have this distribution that you're
fine-tuning of wt's a h is a typo again
h t minus 1 plus b so now every time i
have this
um i'm predicting these words from word
one i predict word two or two predict
word three etc right the actual last
layer of the network unlike before the
last layer of the network has been
pre-trained but i'm still fine-tuning
the whole thing
right so a and b here are mapping to
sort of a probability distribution over
my vocabulary
or the logits of a probability
distribution and um and i just get to
sort of like tweak them now in order to
have the distribution that i'm going to
use reflect the thing like dialog that i
want it to reflect
okay so those are two ways of
interacting with a pre-trained decoder
now here's an example of what is ended
up being the first of a line of wildly
uh
successful or at least talked about uh
pre-trained decoders
so the generative pre-trained decoder or
gpt
was a huge success
um in some sense or at least it got a
lot of a lot of buzz so it's a
transformer decoder no encoder with 12
layers i'm giving you the details so you
can start to get a feeling for how the
size of things changes
uh over the years as we'll continue to
progress here
had each of our each of the hidden
states with dimensionality 768.
so if you remember back to last lecture
we had a term d which was our
dimensionality so d is 768.
and then um
an interesting statement that you should
keep in mind for the engineering-minded
folks is that the actual feed-forward
layers right you've got a hidden layer
in the feed excuse me in the feed
forward layer and this was actually very
large so you had these sort of like
position wise feed forward layers right
and um
and the feed forward layer would take
the 768 dimensional vector sort of like
project it to 3000 dimensional space
do the sort of non-linearity and then
project it back to 768. this ends up
being because uh you can squash a lot
more parameters in for not too much more
compute in this way but so that's that's
curious
okay then and then um by pairing coding
it's actually
was this one by print coding was a
subword vocabulary with 40 000 merges so
40 000 merges so that's not the size of
the vocabulary because you started with
a bunch of characters i don't remember
how many characters they started with
but so it's a relatively small
vocabulary you can see right um and uh
compared to if you tried to say have
every word have a unique uh
representation now it's going to be
trained on books corporates it's got 000
unique books
and it contains long spans of contiguous
text so so you have instead of say
training it on individual sentences just
small short sentences right the model is
able to learn long distance dependencies
because you haven't split like a book
into random sentences and shuffled them
all around you've been you've sort of
kept it contiguous so it can have that
sort of consistency
and then a little little uh treat here
yeah so gpt never showed up in the
original paper or the original blog post
like as an acronym and it could actually
sort of refer to like generative
pre-training which is sort of what like
the title of the paper would suggest or
generative pre-trained transformer
uh and i sort of decided to say
because this seemed like way too general
so gpt
okay so um so they pre-trained this huge
language model transformer this huge
transformer decoder just on 7000 books
and they fine-tuned it on a number of
different tasks and i want to talk a
little bit about the details about how
they fine-tuned it
and
so they fine-tuned it on one particular
task
or family of tasks called natural
language inference
so
in natural language inference we're
labeling pairs of sentences as entailing
or contradictory to each other in
neutral so you have a premise and you
hold the premise as sort of true the man
is in the doorway
and you have a hypothesis the person is
near the door
if this person is referring to that man
uh then you know it's sort of like oh
yeah so this is sort of entailed because
there's a person because a man is a
person and they're in the doorway then
they are near the door
so you have this sort of logical
reasoning that you're doing uh or you're
supposed to be able to be doing and
you're labeling these sentences so it's
a labeled
task you've got sort of an input that's
cut into two parts and then one of three
outputs
okay so um
the the gpt paper evaluates on this task
but what they've got is it is a
transformer decoder so what do they what
do they do um
this is sort of one of the
earlier examples of you know taking
instead of changing your neural network
architecture
to adapt to the kind of task you're
doing
you're going to just format the task as
like a bunch of tokens
and not change your architecture
because the pre-training was so useful
it's probably better to keep the
architecture fixed pre-train it and then
change the task specification to sort of
fit the pre-trained architecture so what
they did right they put this token start
this is a special token
the man is in the doorway some delimiter
token right so this is just a linear
sequence of tokens that we're giving as
one big prefix to gpt
um and then the person is near the door
and then some extra token here right
extract
and then you know the linear classifier
that we talked about and sort of the
first way to interact with models
uh with with decoder models it's applied
to the representation of the extract
token right so you you have the last
hidden state on top of extract and then
you fine-tune the whole network to
predict these labels right and so this
sort of input formatting is increasingly
increasingly used to keep the model
architecture the same and allow for a
variety of different problems to be
solved with it
okay and so did it work on natural
language inference the answer is yes um
so there's a number of different numbers
here uh i wouldn't worry too much about
it the fine-tuned transformer language
model is sort of what you should pay
attention to uh there's a lot of effort
that went into the other models right
and sort of this is the story of
pre-training people put a lot of effort
into models that do various sort of
careful things and then you take a
single transformer and you say
i'm going to pre-train it on a ton of
text and not worry too much about
anything else and just fine-tune it and
you end up doing super super well
sometimes not too much better in the gpt
case than sort of the
best known state-of-the-art methods but
usually a little bit better and again
the amount of effort the amount of task
specific effort that you have to put
into it is very low
okay and so what about the other way of
interacting with decoders right so we
had we said that we could interact with
the coders just by sampling from them
just by saying well they're probability
distributions so um we can use them in
their capacities as language models and
so gpt2 this is just really just a
bigger gpt
don't worry too much about it
with larger hidden units more layers
when it was trained on more data it was
shown to produce sort of relatively
convincing samples of natural language
so so this is something that went around
twitter a lot right so you have this
sort of contrived example that probably
didn't show up
in the training data that has you know a
scientist discovering a herd of unicorns
and then um they sort of sample from
a
um
almost the distribution of the model
they sort of give the model some uh some
uh some extra credit here
they do something called truncating the
distribution of the language models to
sort of cut out
noise at uh in gpt2 so it's not exactly
a perfect sample but more or less gpt2
generated this
and so you have the scientists
discovering unicorns and then you know
you have this consistency okay there's
the scientist
uh you know you have them giving it a
name um you have you refer back to
this uh
well
yeah you refer back to the scientist's
name um you sort of have these like
topic consistency things also the syntax
is really good uh it looks you know
vaguely like english
and so this is sort of continued to be a
trend as we get larger and larger
language models we actually sample from
them even when we give them prompts that
look sort of odd and they seem to be
increasingly convincing
okay
so um
pre-training encoders
okay uh pre-training encoders let's uh
take another second because i need some
more water here
if there's another question let me know
all right
so um so the the benefit of encoders
that we talked about was that they get
this bi-directional context so you can
while you're building
representations of your
sentence of your parts of sentences you
can look to the future and that can help
you build a better representation of the
word that you're looking at right now
but the big problem is that we can't do
language modeling now so we've pretty
much only said like we've relied on this
task that we already knew about language
modeling to do our pre-training but now
we want to pre-train encoders and so we
can't we can't use it so what are we
going to do
um
here's the here's the solution that was
come up with a
paper that introduced the language mod
of the
model called burt
it's called masked language modeling so
um
here's the idea we we get the sentence
and then we just take a fraction of the
words and we replace them with a sort of
a mask token a token that's um that
means you don't know what this is right
now and then you predict these words
some details we'll get into in the next
slide but um so here's what it looks
like right we have the sentence i mask
to the mask
we get some hidden states for all of
them right so we haven't trained we
haven't changed
the transformer encoder at all
we've just said okay here's like this
sequence you get to see everything right
look at all the arrows going everywhere
but then um
right we have this prediction layer
uh that would that were that we're
pre-training right and we're using it we
only have loss
on the words where we had masks here so
i had this masked and then i have to
predict that it was wendt that went here
and store that went here
and now this is a lot like language
modeling you might say
but now you don't need to have this sort
of left to right decomposition
you're saying
i'm going to remove some of the words
and you have to predict what they are
this is called masked language modeling
and it's been very very very effective
with a quick caveat it gets a little
more complicated so um
so what did they actually do they
proposed mass language modeling um and
they released the weights of this of
this pre-trained transformer with a
little bit more complexity to get mass
language modeling to work
so
you are going to take a random 15 of the
sub word tokens
so that was that was true but you're not
always going to replace them with mask
you can think of it like
if the model sees a mask token
it gets a guarantee that it needs to
predict something
and if the model doesn't see a mask
token it gets a guarantee that it
doesn't need to predict anything so why
should it bother building strong
representations of the words that aren't
masked
and i want my model to build strong
representations of everything so we're
going to add some sort of uncertainty to
the model so what we're going to do is
for those fifteen percent of tokens
eighty percent of the time we're going
to replace it with a mask that was our
original idea of mass language modeling
uh then uh ten percent of the time we're
actually going to replace the word with
just a random token just a random
vocabulary item
it could be anything
and then the other 10 of the time we're
going to leave the word unchanged
so now right it sees a word
it could be a random token or it could
be unchanged
um and if i see a mask i know i need to
predict it
so what these two things do here is say
you have to sort of be doing this that
you have to be on your toes for every
word in your in your representation so
here i pizza to the mask
right it turns out and the model didn't
know this but it's getting three loss
terms uh for the sentence it only has
one mask but it's going to be penalized
for predicting three different things it
needs to predict that this word is
actually went
so i replaced this one
it needs to predict that this word is to
is in fact the word to
and then it needs to predict that this
word is in fact
store now as a short interlude you might
be thinking you might be thinking john
there's no way the model could know this
it's so underspecified you know
okay i pizza is a little weird i admit
but there's just no way to know that
there's a store and went into i mean the
tr the same thing is true of language
modeling right so it's going to end up
learning these average statistics about
what things tend to be in the given
context and it's going to you know sort
of hedge its bets and try to build a
distribution of what things could appear
there so for the people who are thinking
that if there was any that's what you
should be thinking it has to sort of
know what kinds of things will end up in
these slots it has other uncertainty
right because it can't be sure that any
of the other words are necessarily
right
um and then it is you know it's
predicting these three words
okay and so
uh that's
you can see why it's important to not
just have masks potentially to have
these sort of like token randomization
things because again we don't actually
care about its ability to predict the
masks right like i'm not going to
usually i'm not going to actually sample
from the model's distribution over what
should go here
instead i am going to you know use the
parameters of the neural network and
expect that it built strong
representations of language so i don't
want it to think it's got a free pass
for representing something if it doesn't
have a mask there
okay so um
there was a one extra thing with the
burp pre-training
um
which is a next sentence prediction
objective so so the input to bert looks
like this this is straight from the burp
paper you have a you have a label here
before your first sentence and then a
separation and then a second sentence so
you had always two contiguous chunks of
text
um you had the first chunk of text here
my dog is cute and then a second check
of text he likes playing
right you can see the sub there and um
now these would actually be both be much
longer right so this whole thing would
be 512 words this would be about half
and that would be about half and they'd
be contiguous chunks of text
but here was the deal what they wanted
to do
was they wanted to try to teach the
system to understand sort of
relationships between different whole
pieces of text
in order to better pre-train for
objectives for downstream applications
like question answering where you have
two pretty different pieces of text and
you need to know how they relate to each
other so the objective they came up with
was you should pre you should
sometimes have the second chunk of text
be the
actual chunk of text that directly
follows the first in your data set
and sometimes have the second check of
text be
randomly sampled from somewhere else so
unrelated
and the model should predict
whether it's the first case or the
second in order again to sort of have to
reason about the relationships between
the two chunks of text
so this is next sentence prediction i
think it's important to think about
because again it's a very different idea
of pre-training objective than language
modeling and masked language modeling
even though later work sort of argued
that in the case of bert it's not
necessary or useful um and one of the
arguments is actually because
it's actually way better to have
a con a single context that's twice as
long so you can learn even longer
distance dependencies and things and so
whether the objective itself would be
useful if you could always just double
the context size i'm not sure if
anyone's done research on that but again
it's like a different kind of objective
and it's still noising something about
the input right the input was
this big chunk of text and you've noised
it to say like now you don't know
whether it really was that or whether
you sort of replaced it with a bunch of
garbage
this sort of second portion here
whether the second portion has been
replaced with something uh yeah has been
replaced with something that didn't
actually come from the same sequence
okay so let's talk some details about
bert
um so bert had 12 or 24 layers depending
on bert base or bert large you'll
probably use one of these models or one
of the sort of descendants of these
models if you just choose to do
something with the custom final project
potentially or if you choose um the the
version of the default file project
and you had you know a 600 or a thousand
dimension hidden states a bunch of
attention heads so this is that
multi-headed attention remember but a
bunch of them so you're splitting your
all your dimensions into those 16 heads
and we're talking on the order of a
couple hundred million parameters
at the time right in 2018 we were like
whoa that's a lot of parameters
how do you you that's a lot of
parameters um and now models are way way
way way bigger so let's keep track of
sort of the model sizes as we're going
through this and let's come back now to
the to the corpus sizes as well so we
have books corpus this is the number of
words there this is the same thing that
gpt uh gpt one was trained on 800
million words now we're going to train
on
also english wikipedia
it's 250 sorry that's 2500 million so
that's 2.5 billion words um
and uh
again to give you an idea of what is
done in practice right pre-training is
expensive and impractical for most
users let's say
so
if you are a researcher with a gpu or
five gpus or something like that
you tend to not really be pre-training
your whole own bert model unless you're
willing to spend a long time doing it
burt itself was pre-trained with 64 tpu
chips a tpu is a special kind of
hardware accelerator that accelerates
the
tensor operations effectively is
developed by google
so tpus are just
fast
and can hold a lot
and uh for four days they had 64 chips
so if you have one gpu which you can
think of as less than a single tpu
uh you're going to be waiting a long
time to pre-train but
tuning actually fine tuning is so fast
it's so fast and practical it's common
on a single gpu you'll see how much
faster fine tuning is than pre-training
in assignment five um and so this
becomes i think like a refrain of the
field you pre-trained once or a handful
of times right like
a couple of people released big
pre-trained models and then you
fine-tune many times right so you you
save those parameters from pre-training
and you fine-tune on all kinds of
different problems
and that that paradigm right taking
something like bert or whatever the best
descendant of bert is and uh taking it
pre-trained and then fine-tuning it on
what you want is
pretty close to
you know i it's a very very strong
baseline in nlp right now right so
and the simplicity is pretty fascinating
and there's there's one uh code base
called transformers from a company
called hugging face that makes this just
really uh just a couple of lines of
python to try out as well so it's sort
of opened up
very strong bass lines without too too
much effort for a lot of tasks
okay so um let's talk about evaluation
so pre-training is pitched as requiring
all this different kind of language
understanding and the field is the field
of nlp has a hard time doing evaluation
but we try our best and we build data
sets that we think are hard for various
reasons because they require you to know
stuff about language and about the world
and about reasoning and so when we
evaluate whether pre-training is getting
you a lot of sort of general knowledge
um
we oh boy uh we evaluate on a lot of
these tasks so um we evaluate on things
like paraphrase detection on quora
questions
natural language inference we saw
we have hard sentiment analysis data
sets or what were hard sentiment
analysis data sets a couple years ago um
actually figuring out if sentences are
grammatical tends to be hard
determining the textual similarity the
semantic similarity of text can be hard
paraphrasing again natural language
inference on a very very small data set
so this is this does pre-training help
you train on smaller data sets the
answer is yes sort of thing and so um
right so the bert folks released their
paper after gpt was released and there
were a lot of sort of state-of-the-art
results that came from various things
that you were supposed to be doing um
and uh
you know the the results that you get
sort of with pre-training so here's
openai's gpt here's bert base and large
the last three rows are all pre-trained
elmo is sort of in the middle uh it's
sort of in the middle between
pre-training the whole model and just
having word embeddings that's what this
is um
and and the numbers you get are just
i think to the field were quite
astounding actually um we were all
surprised that there was that much left
to even be gotten on some of these data
sets and you know taking here so this
this line in the table is unmarked but
it's actually the number of training
examples this data set has 2.5 000
training examples and before sort of the
the big transformers came around we had
60 accuracy on it we run transformers on
it we get 10 points just by pre-training
and this has been a trend that has just
continued
so why do anything but pre-train
encoders right like we know encoders are
good and we we we like the fact that you
have bidirectional context we also saw
that bert did better than gpt
um but you know it has if you want to
actually
get it to do things right
you can't just generate it
generate sequences from it the same way
that you would from a model like gpt a a
pre-trained decoder right you can sort
of sample what things should go in a
mask so here's a mask
you can put a mask somewhere sample the
words that should go there but if you
want to sample whole context right if
you want to get that story about the
unicorns for example um the encoder is
not what you what you want to do so they
have sort of different uh contracts that
can be used
naturally at least in different ways
okay so let's talk very briefly about
extensions of bert so there are burnt
variants like roberta and spanbert and
there's just a bunch of papers with the
word burt in the title that did various
things two very strong takeaways roberta
train bert longer bert is under fit
train it on more data train it for more
steps spanbert
uh mask contiguous spans of sub words uh
of words makes a harder more useful
pre-training task so this is the idea
that we can come up with better ways of
noising the input of of hiding stuff in
the input or breaking stuff in the input
for our model to correct um so you know
for example if you have the sentence
mask ear resist
mask good it's just not that hard
to know that this is irresistibly
right because like what could this
possibly be after these sub words so
this is ear resist
you know
something's got to come here and it's
probably the end of that word whereas if
you mask a long sequence of things right
now this is much harder and actually
you're getting a useful signal that is
irresistibly good and you sort of needed
to mask all of them to make the task
interesting so spanbert
was like oh you should do this
so this was super useful as well
so roberta just to point you with the
fact that roberta showed that bert was
under fit um you know he said burt was
trained on about 13 gigabytes of text it
got some accuracies you can get
above the amazing results of bert four
extra points
or so here right just by taking the
identical model and training it on more
data with a larger batch size for
for a long time
and if you train it yeah on even longer
without sort of more data
you don't get any better
very briefly okay so
very briefly on the encoder decoders so
we've seen
decoders can be good because we get to
play with the contracts that they give
us we get to play with them as language
models encoders give us that
bi-directional context so encoder
decoders maybe we get both
um in practice they're actually yeah
pretty pretty strong um so so there was
a
right we could so but i guess one of the
questions is like what what do we do to
pre-train them
so we could do something like language
modeling right where we take a a
sequence of words word one uh to word uh
two t instead of t
right and so as i have word one here dot
dot word t we provide those all to our
encoder and we predict on none of them
and then we have word t plus one to word
two t here in our decoder
right and we predict on these so we're
doing language modeling on half the
sequence and we've taken the other half
to have our bi-directional uh encoder
right so we're building strong
representations on the encoder side
not predicting language modeling on any
of this and then we on the other half of
the tokens we predict you know as a
language model would do
and the hope is that you you sort of
pre-train both of these well through the
one language modeling loss up here
and this is actually so this works
pretty well the encoder benefits from
bi-directionality the decoder you can
use to train the model but what um this
paper uh
showed that introduced the model t5
ruffle it all um found to work best was
actually a very or at least a somewhat
different objective and this should keep
in your mind sort of that we have
different ways of of specifying the
pre-training objectives and they will
really work differently from each other
so what they said let's say you have an
original text like this thank you for
inviting me to your party last week
we're going to define variable length
spans in the text to replace with a
unique symbol that says something is
missing here and then we'll replace and
then we'll we'll remove that so now our
input to our encoder is thank you
symbol
one
me to your party symbol to weak
right so we've noised the input we've
hidden stuff in the input
also really interestingly right this
doesn't say how long this is supposed to
be
that's different from bert right burt
said oh you masked this many subwords
this says well i got some token that
says something's missing here and i
don't know what it is i don't even know
how many sub-words it is um and then so
you have this in your encoder and then
your decoder predicts the first
special word this x here
and then what was missing
for inviting so thank you x x for
inviting and then it predicts y here's
this y here and then what was missing
from the y last last week
this is called span corruption and it's
really interesting to me because you
know in terms of the actual encoder
decoder we don't have to change it
compared to whether we if we were just
doing language modeling pre-training
because i just do language modeling on
all these things i just predict these
words as if i'm a language model i've
just then done a text pre-processing
step
right so
the actual i've just pre-processed the
text to look like oh yeah take the input
make it look like this then make an
output that looks like that up there
and uh
the model gets to you know do what is
effectively language modeling but it
actually works better so there's a lot
of numbers i realize um but take a look
at the star here this encoder decoder
with a denoising objective that tends to
work the best and they tried similar
models like a prefix language model
um that was sort of the first
uh
try that we had defining a pre-training
objective for language models sorry for
encoder decoders
um
and then they had another a number of
other options but what worked best for
the encoder decoders
and one of the fascinating things about
t5 is that you could pre-train it and
fine-tune it on questions like when was
franklin d roosevelt born and
fine-tuned it to produce the answer
and then you could ask it new questions
at test time and then it would retrieve
the answer from its parameters with some
accuracy and it would do so relatively
well actually and it would do so maybe
25 of the time on some of these data
sets with 220 million parameters then at
11 billion parameters right this is way
bigger than bert large it would do so
even better sometimes even doing as well
as systems that were allowed to look at
stuff other than their own parameters so
again this is just making this answer
come from its parameters
um
yeah i'm gonna have to skip this um so
if you look back at this slide after
class i have each of the examples of the
things that we could imagine learning
from pre-training with a label of what
you might be learning so this example is
stanford university is located in blank
you might learn trivia in all these
cases there's all these things you can
learn one thing i will say is that
models also learn
and can make even worse
racism sexism all manner of bad biases
that are encoded in our text when i say
you know yeah they
they do this and so we'll learn more
about this in our later lectures but
it's important to keep in mind that when
you're doing pre-training you're
learning a lot of stuff and not all of
it is good
so with gpt three the last thing here is
that um
there's this third way of interacting
with models that's related to treating
them as language models so uh
gpt-3 is this very very large model that
was released by open ai
and it seems to be able to learn
from examples in their context their
decoder contexts without gradient steps
simply by looking sort of within their
history
and now gpt3 has 175 billion parameters
right the last t5 model we saw was 11
billion parameters
and and uh it seems to be sort of the
the canonical example of this working
and so what it looks like is you give it
as part of its prefix thanks goes to
merci hello goes to mint goes to right
so you've got these translation examples
you ask it for the last one and it comes
up with the correct translation
seemingly because it's learned something
about the task that you're sort of
telling it to do through its prefix and
so you might do the same thing with
addition so something put something 5
plus 8 is 13. give it addition examples
it might do the next addition example
for you um or maybe uh
trying to figure out grammatical or
spelling errors for example and here's
the the the french to england the
english to french
case so again you're learning just to do
pre-training
uh but at when you're evaluating it you
don't even fine-tune the model you just
provide prefixes
um and so this especially is not well
understood
uh and there's a lot of research is
going into sort of what the limitations
of this
so-called in-context learning are but
it's a fascinating direction uh for
future work um in total these models are
not well understood
however small small in air growth models
like burt have become general tools in a
wide range of settings and they do have
these issues about learning all these
biases about the world they'll go into
and further lectures in this course um
uh
and so yeah what you've learned this
week transformers and pre-training form
the basis or at least the baselines uh
for much of natural language processing
today
and assignment five is out and you'll be
able to look more into it
and i'm over time all right
yeah
i guess i can take a question if there's
a if there is any but people can get
going as well
so i think i think there's a question
about design which was
x or
y it's hierarchy of predicting x or y
uh
i guess it doesn't specify this sort of
sense um how does it know that it's
currently to be used
okay yeah yeah that makes sense so what
did what it does right so it knows from
the encoder that it has to at some point
predict x and at some point predict why
because the encoder can just like
remember that oh yeah there's two things
missing and if there were more spans
replaced there would be a z and then an
a and then a b and you know whatever
just a bunch of unique uh in
you know identifiers and then up here
um it gets to say okay i have a tension
i suppose i can look and i know that
first i have to predict this you know
first masked thing so i'm going to
generate that in my decoder and then it
you know gets that symbol right so we're
doing training by giving it the right
symbol now it gets that x and it says
okay i'm predicting x now
right and now it can predict predictor
predict predict then it gets y so we're
doing this teacher forcing training
where we give it the right answer after
penalizing it if it's wrong now it gets
this y
right and says okay now i have to
predict what should go and why and it
can attend you know into the natural
parts of this as well as what it's
already predicted here because the
decoder has a tension within itself
and it can see what should go there so
what's fascinating here is you're doing
something like language modeling but
when you're predicting why right you get
to see what came after it and that's i
think one of the benefits of span
corruption so you're doing this thing
where you don't know how long you should
be predicting for like language modeling
but you get to know what came after
the thing that's missing
you